hi we are the cast of cobra kai and
we're guest correspondents for wired
and today we'll be testing and reviewing
martial arts tech
[Music]
all right first gadget please
oh my god i feel like it's a hand
strength thing it looks like a swing i
don't know what's like this
tiger claw eagle catcher eagle catcher
is great for building strength in your
hands
and fingers individual resistance spring
provides focus workout for each finger
shaolin said nice wow i wanted this
thing for my kung fu training i can
reposition my fingers in order to work
different parts of my hand simple old
school like device that is easy to use
five stars success book club said i'm
sorry i don't trust this already because
you're a book club not a karate person
but whatever this does not work well all
caps and bolted i do not recommend this
piece of exercise equipment it is not
easy to use and cannot be adjusted to
fit oh he's got small hands to fit
different size hands or hamstrings one
star yeah i'm sorry if your hands are
even smaller than this
i feel like the goal is
your eyes
that's copyright careful
oh
maybe this is really good and we just
don't know how to use it it seems so
situational
i'd say like it it does its job
i'm sure it does what it's supposed to
do five out of five
oh shoot it's like a mini box
oh it's like a handle in the back i just
love this oh i hope this is not a big
like
yeah i think it's got to be a catching
mitt boxing mit human head it says the
head shape helps increase punching
accuracy lightweight helps increase
punching speed left and right hooks
uppercuts leg kicks leg kicks how was
that okay slipping punches
and so much more boxing kickboxing mma
muay thai and karate training benjamin
sensei says pretty good purchase this
piece of equipment is worth it i think
the only drawback was that the handle
rubbed my hand pretty bad i would
recommend having glove on five stars
cj805 said hard to hold not very
effective doesn't hold well for striking
the handle should be in the center not
on the back because it just flops side
to side uncontrollably when someone
throws hooks even light ones can take
jabs and crosses okay one star
all right you want it like this like
this like that you're just gonna let go
let's see if i come in here
i think the guy gave it a one star was
just mad and didn't think of it in a
creative way like we did yeah i i think
this one i actually liked this one more
than the last one it was i think i think
four stars though because you're right
if you could wear it as a mix yeah
it was satisfying though other than that
yeah four and a half stars and it smells
bad so four stars
can we have the third gadget please
they're boards that you can break but
you can put them back together so you're
not wasting
their environmentally friendly
rebranding
boards
victory martial arts branded rebreakable
karate boards are made with premium
quality high impact molded plastic with
rubber padding on both sides break slide
back together and break again different
colors equal different levels of
difficulty match the board thickness
with your belt level to get an idea of
the thickness you need cassie said it
breaks again and again the cushioning is
a nice touch although it doesn't make a
lot of difference five stars too hard to
break
didn't expect it to be so hard to break
one star sorry you're a green belt buddy
three
two one
tanner's like it really hurts
did it hurt
[Applause]
all right what do you guys think the
last the face one was more fun
but you'll get the most use out of this
one but it's environmentally friendly
where's the brick one five out of five
so five stars for that five stars five
stars five stars
may i please have the next gadget
oh i know this one yeah
this could be one of two things play
catch with yourself
yeah it also
raise your reflex poor reflexes in the
ring lead to painful losses ko the
competition when you refine your
reflexes and high-end eye coordination
with champions
reaction ball set ready set spar comes
with one head man four balls with chords
and four extra chords canoedo del leon
said training and entertainment the
product was just as described it's
entertaining and fun for all ages my
four-year-old son and 72 year old dad
have used it it's challenging yet very
straightforward five stars do you hear
that it's for all ages
and then eric said trash it might as
well be garbage the worst part is how
easy it is for the ropes to snap for mma
boxing more like a pathetic child's toy
thing that should be named pathetic one
star i think he's got tiny hands
i think he has tiny hands
oh
world star all right someone else should
try this i'm going to embarrass myself
i'm starting to agree with that eric guy
there you go there you go yeah
i think peyton's right i think it does
feel a bit like a cat but it's really
fun i think it'd be cool to get good i
don't know if i would spend my money on
this but i think if i don't know wired
were to like gift one
gift he's gonna escape with this today
this one party trick i was about to say
this would be a fun like party game if
you lose the party game guys yeah you
take a sip of capri sun yeah you take a
sip of your mountain dew and you do this
mountain dew there we go
good five stars
i actually agree eric was the one who
gave the nasty review right yeah i kind
of agree that with eric that the string
was a little lame i think i would give
it four i would not charge more than
like fifteen dollars i think that would
be scamming people i feel like it's
probably how much is it
may we please have the final
gadget thank you oh it's r2d2 i feel
sturdy i mean this feels pretty cheap
you know what this is it's a holder it's
fushiki
a vibrating massage ball vibration
technology improves range of motion and
flexibility reduces soreness and
stiffness and enhances muscle
performance goodbye pain use it like a
fitness roller on your hand foot neck
body or whatever you see fit bohab said
i have one of these and two of the
larger versions this one is good for
smaller body areas you don't want the
full force of the larger version the
vibes on this are strong love them both
we know what the vibes mean yeah
gs said not nearly enough vibration to
be more beneficial than a ball i guess
the small size is limiting for vibration
amount one star
oh there we go intensity what are you
thinking
i mean i'm gonna agree that it's not
great
hey yeah it kind of just feels like your
phone is buzzing but what if you like
laid on it wait wait wait wait it's like
it feels like your phone is buzzing yeah
it feels like you just have white noise
on your back
oh my god
that went up my spine
maybe try it on the top of your thigh
i like
it i think i think you would bow have on
this one
this would go in my junk drawer for sure
oh
that was the most savage this is like
all day this is like a wrap it's gonna
go in my junk and then you never
yeah okay this thing is not that good
okay the difference is that last thing
was twenty dollars and this is like a
hundred and fifty dollars
it's gonna
[Music]
awesome guys yeah those are all five of
the gadgets what'd you guys think of
them
it's like a pretty even split i like the
face launcher the reusable boards i like
the carrot on the stick the most yeah
not to introduce them yeah too hard
draining yeah
catch us next time see you next time
[Music]